hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of Molyneux masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who have
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're gonna look at how a high
school dropout who was always in trouble
with the law
turns his life around by believing in
himself he went on to become a two-time
world boxing champion and a
multi-millionaire entrepreneur this is a
story of boxing great George Foreman and
a top three lessons that you can learn
from his success
George big George Foreman is an Olympic
gold medalist
two-time former world heavyweight boxing
champion in entrepreneur a high school
dropout
as a teenager Foreman didn't know how to
read or write he took to the streets and
got in the trouble by picking pockets
and mugging people his sister told him
you'll never be anything after finding
himself on the run from the police one
night and digging himself into a pile of
mud to avoid their dogs finding him
Foreman decided he had to change his
life he enrolled in a job skills
training program for youth and began
learning how to read and write
he later also learned how to box and
entered into amateur competitions so he
could send fifty dollars home to his
mother every month after a year and a
half of learning the Box he entered into
the Olympic Games and won the gold medal
he went on to win the world heavyweight
boxing championship twice after twice
retiring from professional boxing
Foreman became an entrepreneur and
toured the world selling George Foreman
grills in 2002 alone the company earned
922 million dollars from selling the
grills Foreman would go on to earn three
times more money from the grills than
throat his entire career as a boxer he
has also moved on to selling TV shows
clothing books and IndyCar racing teams
even though nobody thought he'd ever
accomplished anything in his life George
Foreman turned his life around by
believing in himself and went on to
become a champion boxer and entrepreneur
to help you turn your business into a
success
here are three auction items and you can
learn from George Foreman auction item
number one learn how to sell if you want
to be a successful entrepreneur you need
to develop the ability to sell selling
isn't just convincing customers to buy
our products or services selling is
getting employees media investors
suppliers and everyone else was involved
in your business to believe in what
you're doing it starts with a strong
passion for what you're creating if you
love what you're doing I think you can
really help people it's easy to get
people excited about it and draw others
in if you don't really believe in what
you're doing why should others believe
in you after Foreman came back to boxing
and at 44 years of age became the oldest
person ever to become a champion he
started getting calls to endorse
companies and become their spokesman
when they saw he could sell anything
from food appliances to cleaning
products the companies lined up to get
him to represent them from Doritos to
Kentucky Fried Chicken to McDonald's
Foreman went to work selling her
products and people listened according
the foreman in time I learned the
importance of selling I love selling if
you learn the sell it's worth more than
a degree it's with more than the
heavyweight championship of the world
it's even more important than having a
million dollars in the bank learn to
sell and you'll never starve
auction auto number to get people to
like you people like buying from people
they like the more you can get your
customers to like you as a person the
more likely it is they're gonna buy from
you people also prefer Bynes than people
rather than corporations make sure you
show your clients to history and the
people behind your company talk about
how and why you started the business and
the impact that you're having the more
personal you can make it the more people
are gonna like you and the more they're
gonna want to buy from you during his
early boxing career people hated George
Foreman inside and outside of the ring
he stormed into the ring with rage
didn't have much finesse to his game he
was in it for the money at the start and
didn't care what other people thought of
him he even showed up the one fight
against Muhammad Ali with an angry
German Shepherd by his side to try to
intimidate his opponent but in order for
him to be an effective salesperson he
had to change his persona and get people
to like him according to Foreman I get
mad at the critics other boxers I wanted
to destroy everybody with my fists I
figure I'm gonna make a lot of money I
didn't care about nothing else but
making a lot of money I didn't care
people like me I caught off all my hair
on my mustache I didn't want to be
identified with the old guy I learned to
make people love me to get my message
across when I had to change the box
again
I saw boxing not as a sport the second
time around but is pure business which
meant making meetings and trying to make
myself attractive to Madison Avenue
action of number three keep trying until
it works it's rare that entrepreneurs
make it big off their first idea and
even if they do the idea has changed
many times from what they thought they
were gonna create failing is a part of
business the key is to get started
too many people don't start because
they're afraid of failing you will know
failure keep going
fail smarter the next time and
eventually success will be yours Foreman
is an afraid of failing in business he's
done everything from specialty shoes
made for diabetics to a health food
restaurant chain to a reality television
series he's willing to try almost
anything if he thinks it might be a good
opportunity and it's something he
believes it as long as the business is
something he can feel proud of and won't
damage his integrity Foreman is willing
to stretch his brand to do almost
anything you never know until you try
according to Foreman you've got to start
out early in the morning and look at
hundreds literally hundreds of things
and it may take a year it may take three
or four years but you're going to hit
something so you have something to put
on the table for your family you know
you put out a lot of buckshot
you're gonna strike one so remember
learn how to sell get people to like you
and keep trying until it works to finish
up this video I wanted to share one of
my favorite true stories about George
Foreman and some of his best quotes with
a criminal record and a reputation for
being a troublemaker whew gave Foreman a
chance when he joined the u.s. job corps
looking for a way to get off the streets
he caused so many problems that he was
almost expelled from the program
his supervisor advised him to find a
different outlet for his anger and
suggested he take up boxing when Foreman
first started the box he was so scared
that he just closed his eyes and swung
his massive fists to win the fights it
was only until he started going up
against better boxers that he had to
learn the fight with his eyes open
thank you so much for joining me for
another edition of Mali in the masters
if you liked the video I want to see
more please give it a thumbs up below
I'd also love to hear oh you have to
think if you wanna leave a comment
underneath the video and stay tuned for
next episode
you